Hey Hey Hey We were I just need you guys to know we were
dancing To the opening Boom Boom Boom Boom
Why aren't you dancing?
Come on Doki Lift those wings!
Lift those wings!
Wait, you don't like it when you see my way
It's a little It's a little freaky Yeah, that's why
We were dancing to the opening so that's why I took a so
long guys we were busy dancing to the opening sorry we were
15 minutes yeah for like we get closer look how fucking huge
she is compared to me okay when i came in you were so you
were like okay that's true that's true i was like i was like
this oh god damn this is this is irl uh height difference
right there actually you should be a little bit shorter you
are No, okay.
That's a dramatization.
I feel like I'm in danger.
Don't make you, make me put you in the box.
Oh my god.
I'll put you in the box.
Why does my vision go black when I'm close to the box?
Yeah, it's programmed so you can't see anything if you're in
the box.
it's my special box I think I'm addicted how's the volume
guys how's the volume chat so far let me be tiny again I
feel too big in this room you feel tiny so I can squish you
I can kick you in the shins oh wait I'm like Matt, I'm,
like, perfect.
So what are you doing?
Why are you, like, poking my belly button?
Your arms are too short.
You can't even raise them up.
I don't need to raise them up.
Raise me up.
Whoa.
You jump really high.
Oh.
Hey, guys.
Today is not a special day.
It's just a normal day.
We just...
It's a normal day, guys.
we do have an announcement together but like other than that
it's just a normal day huge shout out to mint because like
literally i asked her yesterday if she could do this and she
and then she like uploaded her vr chat model like like what
was an hour before yeah 10 minutes ago yeah she she got it
got it under 10 minutes we had to message like like VR chat
staff and be like, we don't know what to do.
I don't know what to do.
VR chat staff help us.
The worst part, the worst part is I finally got it.
Maybe a minute after or a minute before they uploaded it for
me.
What?
So I have a backup.
Oh, that's good.
That's good.
You have a backup.
Okay, they were so helpful.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Thank you VR chat team.
They gave us free stuff.
we have like membership now what was it called though they
gave us like vr plus yeah we got vr plus yeah we love free
we love free i don't know what we can do with it but like
it's free so that's all that matters you know free stuff
yeah i'm actually jumping oh wait you
No, it doesn't track it.
Can you raise you up a little bit?
Is it voices?
Um, I assume it's voices, right?
I'm going to raise you up a little bit higher.
75%.
Oh, yeah.
We want to take you to Chicken Topia.
We're going to be exploring VR chat worlds.
Yeah, we don't have to worry about copyright.
I know you took them to, like, the snake place.
Metal Gear Solid places.
Oh, yeah.
I took them to Metal Gear Solid.
last time yeah wait the snake place yeah the snake place
there's like snakes in the water all right wait you had open
right maybe oh yeah i can put that thing for us yeah i saw
it on like my twitter for you page it was like basically we
raise chickens and we put them in a box and then we send
them up into the air to die i guess yeah where they go to
chicken heaven they're gonna to chicken heaven like all dogs
go to heaven oh um that's okay wait what do you mean drop a
portal all right yeah there you go yay all right see you
there whoa sorry i have to like technical difficulties but
here we go well here we go for real
This is a normal day.
Just a normal streaming day.
Oh, I need to be a bit louder.
Let me double check.
Whoa.
That's my face.
Is that my face?
Oh, that is.
Okay, let me put myself a little louder.
Okay.
Have you ever been here before?
Whoa.
No, I haven't.
Looks real.
Whoa.
This looks amazing.
It looks crazy.
Yeah, okay, you guys can't see it.
There's a lot of birds.
Oh, my God.
Guys, look.
Oh, the lighting changes everything.
Wait, that's so cool.
Wow.
Okay, let me get my...
There's birds everywhere.
Where's the camera?
Where's the...
It's right in front of you.
You're holding it.
I'm literally holding it.
No, no, not that one.
It's like the pin one.
It looks...
Okay, anchor.
Oh, we have to...
Oh, I forgot.
You have to, like...
Put like this thing here the local You're so close I'm gonna
take a screenshot Stop I'm gonna take a screenshot There we
are They oh my god look at that Look oh my god Look at the
shading on this Yeah I know it's beautiful It's so crazy
Okay let's see behavior Don't look at me okay don't maybe i
can't mint i'm not very good at this i'm not
i don't know what's the perfect the perfect you know angle
the perfect camera angle I always I put it behind me I put
it behind me and then they get to like watch me Oh see how
you're so smart it's like they're traveling with us Yeah
it's like POV you know like that one with the girl and then
she holds her hands out like this and then you're like
holding your hand and you're like yay Let's go like that you
remember that YouTube video yeah yeah yeah yeah Are you
going to hold the Dragoon's hands?
You, that's where they'll get cooties.
Okay, I think you need to let it.
Okay, so you need to like, there's like, it's too close.
All I see is your head.
Yeah.
Okay.
This is all you see.
Hold my hand.
Get the cooties.
I'm good.
I know.
You can't be good.
Yay.
We did it Oh, there you go Yeah, yeah, yeah, and then I put
it local after that And then yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah We did
it, guys We did it We're so good at this Let's go get some
chicken Oh my gosh, wait, wait Where's the chicken?
Right here Over here Oh my god, hey Wait, I need to fix the
camera Where the camera go?
Oh, there Why is the camera over there?
Wait, this is insane Oh my god, whoa!
Fuck, okay, let me put the camera like Oh my god, there's a
flying Where is she going?
Where is she?
Oh my god Oh my god, okay What the fuck?
Did you see that?
Oh my god That was crazy That was crazy.
Okay, I need to figure
It's the simple things and
Where did the camera go I lost the camera?
Where did it go?
It's right here.
Oh, how do you see?
Oh, it is.
It's right here.
Hello guys Do you guys have?
I think the like fish eye lens on it is kind of crazy
There's a fish eye lens on it Yeah, I think so Oh my god I
lost it again Oh there it is, I see it It's so hard to see
it It's right there It's so hard It's so hot.
Oh, there's old old-timey.
We're in the old-time West.
Oh my god.
Wait, they have new.
They have like new filters and everything.
Oh, I see.
Sepio.
Wow.
Yeah, yeah.
Like, the speed's always been there.
I remember the speed.
But like, they have the...
I know like the old one was new.
This was new.
What?
Do you want to say that again?
the old what did you the old one what is it it's literally
titled oh
there's a there's a trippy there's the trippy filter have
you seen the trippy filter there is yeah Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah.
Your head!
My eyes!
We're like a little...
We're like kids at the carnival with the wall of Mary.
We're already...
Ooh!
And then there's...
Ooh, there's the sparkle.
I'm not like the sparkle as much, though.
I think the trippy one was my favorite.
Okay, guys, I figured it out.
I figured out how to use the camera.
Guys, okay.
She figured it out.
Wait, why does it follow me?
Like, in the back.
It doesn't follow me in the back.
What do you mean?
Like, when I move the camera...
Oh, wait, no.
I have to move myself.
And then... Wait, no?
Is the camera...
Are you okay?
Yeah, okay.
Okay, so if I look at this way, do you see my back?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I figured it out.
I figured it out.
All right, we did it, guys.
Okay, now we can check out the chickens.
We did it, Reddit.
Yeah, we did it, guys.
We can check out the chickens.
All right, here's...
Oh, I'm on your front again, but that's okay.
That's okay.
All right.
Why is the...
Where's the chicken?
Wait, so we take a chicken.
Yeah, we take a chicken.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Wait.
We put it in a box.
box oh my god and then if oh my god wait wait and then we
press the button we press the we press this okay we sell it
why are we selling
I want to get a chicken all right dragons I'm gonna grab you
this is you we're gonna sell you dragons we're off to off to
heaven you go you're getting getting into heaven oh my god I
can't get on the box I can't I have a special chicken this
in not it there you go down you go goodbye goodbye everybody
oh my god i'm so far oh holy i'm so far oh my
god yeah you can and then you can spend more money to get
more chickens get more dragons oh wait i have a lot i have a
money how did you get the money
Look at her go.
Wait.
There's my camera.
I'm paying.
I'm paying you.
Oh, I got it.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
Come on, come on.
Oh, come on.
Come on.
Oh, my God.
It says don't forget to feed the chickens.
Do we?
Do we need to feed them?
No, we don't.
I don't know.
I don't think we have to.
Did you get it?
Redeem.
Click it.
Hold on.
I have to push the...
I'm trying.
I think we're too short for this.
Oh, you got to be this way.
You gotta eat this.
I gotta- What is this?
Oh, that's to feed the chickens!
It's an apple.
Wait, but where are the chickens?
Wait, don't get- We got rid of all our chickens.
I think we were supposed to breed the two chickens we have!
I think we're supposed to- I just saw the chickens.
Wait, hold on.
We saw them.
We know it has.
I thought- I thought we had word chickens.
chickens I thought it would give us chicken I didn't realize
we have to breed them we could go find more there's probably
a ton of chickens out there oh no I don't know let's go on
the bus okay on the bus okay yeah the bus wait what it's a
purple chicken wait he came out of the apple yeah I came out
of the apple wait is that where chicken come from where's
our camera so you there it is yeah i'm showing it i'm
showing it look a chicken came out of apples guys every time
you eat an apple you eat in a chicken that's right
vegetarians you are not a real vegetarian because you eat
apples oh wait okay he's fine oh no does he grow up he if
you drop him he's she smushes watch wait
It made a sound!
What the fuck?
He gets really small, aren't he?
Can you like smush it with your hands?
I think I stepped on him earlier.
Oh, see?
I smushed him!
Yeah, you smush him!
Wait, can we get another one?
Do we have more money?
Oh!
Yeah, we have more money!
It made the sound!
Where'd the money go?
Yeah, where's the money go?
You don't you there was another money.
Where's the money what do you do?
What did I do?
Where's the money?
What do you mean?
I do is send chickens out of there.
All I do is send the chickens up in there I don't know
Did we fuck up the world?
Did we mess it up?
Oh, I found it.
I found it.
Oh, okay All right, okay, POV and redeem You are the machine
that she redeems from.
Oh, we're going to get a mushroom monkey.
Oh.
I mean, a monkey.
This is chicken-topia, not mushroom-topia.
This is- I thought it was blooms.
How many hours have you spent on blooms, Mint?
How many hours?
Oh, God, he's huge now.
Oh, my God.
Look, he's big.
He's so big.
Wait, so does that mean we don't feed the chicken?
chicken we just we just get more chickens we don't get two
no I think we feed them right yeah we feed the mushroom to
the chicken yeah where did it go oh my god
I guys I don't I think this chicken has a few medical issues
I think it's on her head It's all...
It's okay, I still love our son.
The chicken sons.
Wait, the chicken sons!
There's an egg!
They made it!
They made it an egg!
We're grandparents!
I'm gonna feed them lots.
Thank you so much, Khan.
Come on.
More babies.
Yeah!
Oh, my God.
Weapon to the egg.
Oh, it's the yellow chicken.
Shad.
Oh, my God.
The first thing it did was eat.
Wait, how did you feed it?
Oh, my God.
They're fighting.
Don't fight.
They're your kind.
Wait, how did you get Caesar?
Oh, how?
Oh, God.
Come on, get some seeds, get some seeds, yes!
Eat, oh shit, I smushed them!
It's okay, they're still alive.
They like it, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
See, they're still fine.
Hey, go guys!
Chicken sons!
Seed!
Where are the eggs?
Oh my god.
That guy's getting really big.
Wait, he is.
Oh my god, there's four eggs!
We're gonna be rich!
We have so many chickens!
I think she's mad with power right now she's mad with power
there's so many chickens oh there's so many you just your
entire body your entire body is covered with chickens we'll
never go hungry again we have all the chickens we can eat
they're what are you talking about this is my army your army
and thus the whiffs evolved into chickens Oh my god.
Wait.
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here.
Okay.
Can anybody see me?
Do you?
Do you see her?
It's okay.
She's in the pile of chickens.
Okay, I give up.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Look at that pink one.
All right.
Who should we sell first?
This guy.
Oh.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh my god.
Did you, can anybody see me?
Wait, did you crash the server?
Did you crash the server?
Oh my god.
Wait.
This guy.
Oh, it's repeating.
It's repeating.
Oh my god.
Can anybody see me?
This guy.
Oh, it's repeating, guys.
It's repeating!
Oh my god!
Can anybody see me?
I'm still here!
This guy.
Holy shit.
Holy shit!
In a loop!
I'm stuck in the loop!
Oh my god, I was stuck in the loop!
That was the craziest shit!
The crash!
Holy shit!
That was loop!
I think Mint fucking crashed the server!
I'm launching back up.
We were looping.
oh my god we were looping we had too many chickens there
were too many chickens oh my god the chickenopolis
apocalypse that was actually crazy i was not expecting the
looping oh i put the volume in already do you guys need it
to be lowered even more too many chickens I didn't realize
there was a limit to how many chickens you can have.
I wonder if I can, like, get an invite.
Like, is she still in Chickentopia?
Is she still there?
Let's me request.
Request invite.
I'm requesting invite right now.
She was too powerful.
The chickens were just too many.
There was just too many chickens.
That was actually crazy.
an actual limit to how many chickens you can have oh my god
there was there was a chicken limit okay don't worry we're
coming back we're coming back right now worlds uh we're
going back to a chicken topia the voice don't worry don't
worry it's a black screen because like i need to get in the
world and then get the camera out i don't have the camera
out yet oh my god oh my god oh my god it got worse how did
it get worse there's so many chickens
okay i'm trying is it there you go all right You don't see
me yet because I'm trying to figure out the but you're gonna
see how there's more chickens How is there more chickens?
What did you do?
I'm selling the chickens How did there more chickens?
You crashed my server
So many chickens We're not making any more money I think we
need to live.
I think we need to live.
You're so...
But they are these chickens!
I think we broke the economy.
They broke the chicken economy.
Why is...
Because they're sold out.
They can't even pay it.
We have too many chickens.
We don't even spend this.
Why?
Why are you still selling?
Because we gotta get rid of these chickens!
You're the one that breed in so many chickens!
Oh no.
I'm trying to hear you!
The great...
The great chicken crash.
I can't believe it.
You burst a chicken bubble!
How did you burst a chicken bubble?
Um...
I don't know.
I can't believe she did.
She burst a chicken economy.
They won't even...
I think we have to breed more chickens Wait, what do you
mean?
To give and sell chickens.
Wait, just pay, get the...
Oh my god, they're following...
They're just...
They're following you.
Holy shit.
It's because I'm their master.
I'm gonna squish all of them.
I'm big boys.
I'm big...
I'm squishing all of them.
Wait, wait, wait.
Don't get it.
I'm the big cock.
I don't know it doesn't really like It's not very effective
when I see you try to jump up and reach it We're gonna get a
square chicken.
Oh my god.
No, that's an ice cube We're gonna get an ice chicken.
We're gonna get a snow chicken Wait, I heard like I heard
fire chicken is weak again.
Wait, I heard like ice chicken is weak against fire Fire
chicken.
So we need to get fire chicken.
We need to get fire chicken.
Oh my god, you're literally like the mom.
It's following you everywhere.
Oh my god.
Wait, we got a strawberry chicken.
We got a strawberry.
Oh no, that's how I die.
Oh my god, the ice chicken.
Look, there's snow coming out of the ice chicken.
You're so cute.
Oh my god.
Oh shit.
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for squishing.
I'm so sorry.
Guys, look.
Look.
Look at there's snow coming out!
Look this one is mine.
Okay.
We're good.
Are you good?
Are you sure?
Wait, what's this one?
Oh this!
Look at the strawberry chicken!
I think it's a ghost!
Wait, is that a ghost chicken?
Oh my gosh!
I think it's a ghost again!
Wait!
Oh my gosh!
Guys, look, I got, we got strawberry chicken too!
Look at him!
This is how I die.
Did you...
Did you just eat the shark?
Gonna die, everybody.
Do as I say, you only live once.
YOLO.
Wait, where's the ghost chicken?
Where is it?
Oh, there it is!
Look!
Wait, that's a wisp!
It's a wisp!
Guys!
I'm gonna eat the wisp.
I'm gonna eat the wisp!
You can't stop!
me guys look there's the wisp there he is there he is oh my
god it's my precious son my precious son there he is wait it
is so cute oh my god it jumped into your head Oh god, he's
so cute.
Haha!
Wait, do we have more?
Where's the- more- Oh my god, that's not ours.
That's not ours.
What do you mean I don't- That's not ours.
Did you- Did you birth that?
Did you birth that one?
That one- that guy's adopted.
That- No, that's adopted.
There's no way!
There's no way I would never love the sun.
I would never love the sun.
Are you- Was nobody in a way?
They didn't even stop!
Oh my god!
She instantly threw away the chicken!
He's still here!
Okay.
Wait, where is he?
Where is he?
Where did he go?
Oh my god, that's not you!
Oh, there's too many!
Guys, this is the son that we don't own.
Whose son is this?
I don't know how we get blessed.
This is not ours!
Who is this ugly son?
Is this a wisp?
What?
Look at the guy.
Look at the guy we just got.
What is he?
He's got glasses
He's cool.
Wait, look he has glasses Look I think this is yours.
I think this is yours.
I think it's mine.
Yeah, he takes after me Wait, this one looks like you!
Wait, what is this?
The fuck?
How is this me?
It looks like you!
How?
It just has a...
It's a...
It's...
Oh yeah, the sun's yellow, is that also me?
This is really what she thinks looks like me, guys.
This is here.
This guy right here.
Okay, I can chat.
You say it looks like her dad.
too right wait where did oh my god the wrist grew up so big
look i know oh what did you feed him i can punch it you know
life force and so that's why i'm so tall i can punch it i
think we just got a boob you just got a what wait wait this
one is broken wait what do you mean What's wrong with it?
Look at it!
What's wrong with it?
It's broken on top!
No, I think it's a flower!
Is this a boob?
Will I get demonetized?
YouTube, is this a boob?
Is this a nipple?
Wait, wait, wait, put it up against your chest, man.
Wait, get over here.
Wait, wait, get over here, man.
Put this against your chest and look at the camera.
Like this?
Yeah, yeah, and then move to...
the move more this move right here move more here and
no wait he's so cool show it he's so cool guys this is it
we're just gonna be in chikotopia forever we can't stop
making more chickens what the fuck this one is an
abomination don't get me this one is an abomination what did
the dog got in I don't know who let the dogs in who let the
dogs out what's wrong with this one is this a boob one it
has like a boob on top that's all you hear is we have so
many we have so all you hear lead them into a better future
come my chickens we will where are you leading this
oh my god
oh my god where are they going where are the chickens going
i don't know look at them go
where are they going there they are there's the chickens the
horde of chickens they're following mint there they go off
to the distant lands okay now we can leave them here and oh
that's true I'll get some more.
I'll get some more.
Did you just...
Did you just abandon your chickens?
My chickens!
Did you just abandon the children?
Yeah.
Follow me, chickens.
This way, chickens.
Bye.
Why aren't they coming?
Wait, are they my chickens?
Wait, I think they follow you.
Oh, they follow me?
Okay, chickens, come over here, chickens!
Come over here!
Wait, they stop following me your chickens are kind of
stupid.
You know my chickens are smart.
They know what we're gonna do They know that they're gonna
get abandoned Your chickens are stupid your chickens are
stupid.
They were like my mama loves me They know yeah, I do I'm
leading them to a greater place.
You're abandoning them.
Why are you?
No, they're here.
They're free.
That's not abandonment.
What will they eat?
What will it wait?
There's one chicken.
There's one chicken that's following you.
You have two chickens behind you What the fuck I do I want
to throw them away Get over here.
Oh my god Okay, why can't you go further?
Get over there there be there with your swan hey came back
be there with your sons we're your friends all right there
they are now run now run okay okay are they following are
they following me just run just run just run where's the
house where's the house okay nice all right nice now we've
reduced the chicken population that's good yeah we did it
but we still can't we still can't sell more we're sold out
like did we max out the you must have maxed out the like
available um chickens yeah here i'll try selling one come
here okay
goodbye no he just falls through the bottom oh they reject
their chickens is it because they're is it because they're
white and they need to be the special ones they don't they
don't take default chickens anymore all right boop chicken
we don't get rid of get rid of toast we're gonna get Toast
get away.
We never wanted you.
I will see you.
Oh We want we wanted toes.
Yeah, we always wanted toes.
Yeah, we're just testing..
We were just testing you wanna see your commitment.
I want to... We've always loved toes..
Yeah, we love Toast.
It's because it has crust on it.
That's what makes it ugly.
There's crust on that toast.
what are you doing I'm putting them in jail
I don't want to see that one anymore oh yeah by the way you
guys haven't seen him we think the dog got to the chickens
because what the fuck is wrong with him like what is wrong
with this guy we might actually be like scientist we created
we created new species the genetics worked it actually
worked guys all right I chose chicken to opiates your turn
oh wait do you want to check out the fortnight bus oh yeah
let's check out the fortnight bus yeah we love fortnight we
love fortnight this is the bus that took us to the whole new
world this is so cute Oh, that's so... Oh my gosh, they
can't see it.
Guys, don't worry, camera.
I'm gonna figure this out.
Guys, I know you can only see the outside of the camera.
Wait, how do I bring it to me?
I'm shutting the doors.
Oh, no, no, you're not gonna let them in!
They're not in yet!
It's too late.
Guys, get in here!
Guys, get in here.
It's not my fault.
I don't know how to use the camera.
Okay, there you go.
Oh, look at it.
There's like...
Oh, maybe these are like supporters and stuff I'm the bus
driver Say thank you to your bus driver guys.
Whoa Thank you bus driver.
Thank you bus driver You're barely you're like phasing just
like a ghost you're phasing through the
That's a lore immersion
Not the chicken Think of the chickens!
I'm dead now.
You're already dead.
Wait, is that how you died?
Is that your ghost lore?
You died from the Fortnite bus.
Died in the Fortnite bus.
That'd be so sad.
Why?
Everybody loves the Fortnite.
Everybody loves the Fortnite bus.
Yeah.
We love Fortnite.
I'm gonna sit I'm gonna sit everybody knows the back sheet
is the best seat I know that's why I'm here yeah that's why
I'm here too yeah that's what that's your camera looking it
is it is it's it's doing its best it's doing it is doing I'm
doing its best guys I'm trying that's all that matters You
can tell that there's effort going in.
All right.
What world should we go next?
Um.
Let's see.
Ooh.
There's so many new things.
It's so hard to...
I know.
There's like...
Chat, where do you want to go?
Chat, give us some suggestions.
What are the hippest new...
There's Omega VR.
Yeah, no.
Stop.
I don't think that probably works as it is.
Omega VR.
Let's see.
Okay.
Where are some good places?
Let's see.
Oh, what's my favorite?
Oh, I only have Chicken Topia.
Chicken Topia!
I mean, it was a pretty good place.
It was.
Chicken Topia.
Wait, how do I see like the popular?
Oh, here we go.
It's trending.
Trending.
Yeah.
Um, we could go to murder for murder for more murdering free
hide out Oh my god, don't either just in your head like give
them something to see What about locks ERP room locks ERP
room?
There's a hundred and There's 128 people in there.
I don't think it's wait.
Do you want to play uno?
Oh my god.
There's uno.
There's husband hotel
there's oh my god oh my god there's a game theory can we go
to Luigi's casino wait let's go okay Luigi's casino and then
my next pick is game theory GT live you see you save that
one yeah I'm adding that to the favorite okay favorite world
one I'm dropping a portal.
I'm dropping a portal.
Yeah, it's out.
I think it's gonna be in the front of the fort Okay, hold
on.
Where's the fortnight bus?
Where is it?
Wait, oh, oh, this way.
It's outside.
Oh, okay.
Where did you drop the portal?
Right there.
Oh, there it is.
Here I go.
Oh my god, Luigi's casino Yay!
Finally Luigi's doing something.
what the fuck what the fuck wait oh my god whoa whoa whoa
whoa okay gotta level up the camera no we have no like
gravity here no wait there's slots there's slots machine
yeah where's luigi Luigi!
We would lie to!
I was promised Luigi!
I was promised Luigi in my Luigi casino!
Okay, behind me.
Guys, we're gonna make it.
Let's go gambling!
Oh man!
Let's go!
Oh dang it!
Now I remember why I don't do my own cameras anymore.
I remember why.
I remember why I have cameramen now.
This is so I tried.
Whoa, I took a photo.
I accidentally took a photo.
What was happening?
I'm trying to... Where did it go?
Where did the camera go?
It's right.
Hold on.
Okay, wait.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
It's right on your face.
It's right here.
Okay, I won't put it here.
And then...
auto level and then world there we go yay i figured it out
oh i didn't figure it out i figured it out this place sucks
wait they're in the table you gotta move oh there you go no
no there's slots right here what's wrong with it what why
just get on the slot machine
Wait, that's it.
That's it.
That's where's Luigi?
We were promised Luigi.
I don't know.
There's no Luigi.
We've been bamboozled for you.
We've been bamboozled.
Where's Luigi?
Why were there 100?
Why is this a trending area?
There's nothing here.
Do people just go, let's go gambling?
Is that it?
Is that what made it trend?
Let's go gambling.
Okay, let's go to the GT Live.
Let's go to GT Live.
Let's do some game theory.
All right, where are those?
Oh, where's my- where's the- oh dang it.
We would lie to.
Okay.
New instance.
Friend plus.
There you go.
Oh my god, the portal thing is different too.
Let's go gambling.
Oh dang it.
Here we go.
I can't believe it!
We got lied to!
Where did our...
Where did our fucking Luigi go?
I was promised Luigi!
Wait.
Where's this?
With the fuck Jacksepticeye in space with Markiplier?
We're on observ- what?
Whoa!
There's observation duty!
You love that game!
Observation!
Oh yeah!
Yeah, there's a bunch of it.
Yeah, I was amazed at the movie.
What is this?
Whoa, there's homestocks here.
Oh, my God, homestock.
Is this copyrighted?
Do you hear this?
Is this copyrighted music?
What is that?
I don't know.
It's all right.
Whatever.
What are you going to do?
Take my ad money?
Here we go.
Oh.
What is this?
What are you guys?
Don't see it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Where's the camera?
I need you guys to see this.
It's right here, it's right here, it's right here, it's
right here.
Oh my god.
Oh shit, look.
What?
It's some song.
Yeah, we don't know what this is.
It says Doki Bird YouTube.com, I think it's you.
Wait, what?
Wait, it's me?
This is who she watches every day, you guys.
Guys, why?
Oh, it's because I have to look at me on.
There you go, guys.
Oh, um, you're getting, you're almost there.
Oh, why is it?
Are you sideways?
Why?
Wait, I didn't know that's a thing.
There you go.
Yeah.
This is what we're watching.
Here, here.
There's so much better at this than me.
Holy shit.
There you go.
Yeah.
Who are these people?
Are you actually listening to it?
Are you allowed to?
Oh, okay.
How creepers get to explode.
I'm like that hat in time gift.
Who is that guy?
Who is he?
He's pretty catchy.
I don't think I'm on full body.
There we go.
Dude, a monster.
A monster?
Whoa!
I heard that.
I smacked it It's a thriller Thriller night
How long is this song this is a five minute song?
No, it's a five minute Hey,
this is like game suggestions for us, I know oh my gosh guys
look um, we'll show you guys the rest of uh The rest of the
place.
Yeah.
Loco.
Look!
This is where MatPat does his theories.
Look at that!
I'm turning off the music.
I can't do this anymore.
Oh, they have a playlist.
Oh, they have a playlist?
Oh, my God!
Doki Doki decoded!
MatPat!
That's what I...
My Oshi!
Oh, my God.
we're gonna figure out the game theory oh my god stop you
can just come here and watch game theory yeah yeah oh my god
we can watch game theory like a like a kid like you know a
stand too close a really rich kid with VR chat with VR no
i'm just like really close to the screen oh my god
my god my pot my pot What?
Where's the intro?
Give me the game theory!
There it is!
Welcome to game theory.
I can't believe he's actually just going off.
Oh my god.
What is the theory?
Among Us.
When the dokiest
Wait, what's this?
Look, what is that?
What is this, guys?
What is it?
Oh, wait, what is that?
Just a theory.
Oh my god.
Oh, it's a soundboard!
What's the Golden Freddy?
What's the Golden Freddy does?
It's probably he's here, he's there, he's everywhere.
Hoor, hoor, hoor.
Hoor, hoor.
Wait, I can't do it.
How do you press it?
How did you press that?
I think you have to be holding it.
Yeah, you have to be holding it first.
Yeah, hoor, hoor, hoor.
We should visit Freddy's Fazbear!
Did you take it?
Where did it go?
I think it went through the wall!
I think it was pasted through the wall!
No, not bad!
How will we know if it's a game, Perry?
How?
Oh, wait, it's on the floor!
Oh, where did it go?
Where?
Oh, it's over there.
Okay, nice.
It was through the floor.
But hey, but, hey, but, but, but.
We're going to go into the wild, but, but.
But, but, but, but, but.
But, hey, that is just a thing.
That's exactly what they did.
Uh, okay, we should- Is it like his house?
I feel a little uncomfortable.
No, this is his office.
Oh, there's beanbags!
There's a pool table?
There's a cat!
Oh, wow, the cook- Whoa!
Whoa!
Doki, put on the mirror.
We're in the game theory.
Oh my god.
Oh, wait, wait, I wanna know.
Wait, wait, I wanna- We're in the game.
Put on the mirror.
Oh my god, we're in the game theory!
We're in the game theory!
This entire time, we were in the...
I probably look like a crazy person.
Wait, it doesn't show on the...
It doesn't show on the camera!
It just looks like we're in the void!
No, we're in the game theory!
No, you don't understand!
We're in the game theory, look!
We're in the game theory!
It's the video!
Right there!
Which one's the real jokie?
I don't know...
Whoa, which one's the real dokey?
Oh, no, they're converging.
They're converging.
Oh, God, why do I look like that?
Oh, my God.
This is Mint's true form.
This is her true form.
You know, like, angel's true form?
Biblically accurate Mint.
If I, if we touch the finger, will we get stuck?
did oh oh i'm scp's mint right there we should we should
visit for now we should visit for now i want to do it though
no i won't i'm not baby is this like an official world
there's like even wait yeah i think so wait are we supposed
to break Oh my god, is there's an ARG in VR chat?
I think so.
Oh my god, there's like codes and stuff.
This is like a code.
Guys, can you guys do this for us?
We're gonna go to FNAF world.
You figured it out.
Guys, Dragoons and Wisp work together and figure out how to
solve Matt Pat's code.
Did they see it?
Hold on, hold on.
Here, here, here, here.
I'll show it to them.
Oh wait, there's a back.
There's a front.
Here's the front.
Yeah, yeah, and then there's a back.
That's the front.
Yeah.
You got it?
Here's the back.
Screenshot it?
Screenshot it.
Yep.
There that is.
Figure it out.
And...
But hey, that's just...
But hey!
...
Whoa, there's big foot.
Yeah, there's big foot.
There's foot birds.
Oh my god.
Wait, guys.
Wait, wait, wait.
Okay, there's a coat on the ceiling.
What?
Where's the camera?
Oh my god, there is.
You guys don't see it.
We're not giving you hints on how to solve this puzzle.
You gotta go there yourself.
No hints for you.
Wait, but we'll show you the feet.
Wait, where's the mirror?
Wait, can we show them the feet again?
Wait, do you guys see it?
It's like right here.
Wait, it's on the wall.
Oh my god, it's on the wall!
What are they doing?
You didn't notice the wall?
It goes all the way up and then it goes to the code.
Oh!
That's some big ass feet.
Third eye.
What is this third eye shit?
Alright, take us to FNAF.
Are we really?
Yeah.
Wait, oh my god, this is just straight up OBS right here.
Yeah, this is...
editing software.
Well, this is how they do the GT Live.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's GT Live.
Oh, you're on the couch!
Oh my god, guys!
She's on the couch!
Wait, let me bring it to me.
Here's the decoder.
Where's my camera?
Oh, there it is.
In front of your face, yeah.
Guys, look!
There she is!
Wait.
Take a nap.
down real quick there's like this camera right there look
and then the couch is like oh where is it the couch is right
there it's a little casting couch yeah for gt live i think
the camera's in your head you gotta like put it far further
away i think like put it where my hand is put it where Yeah,
because when you move forward, it covers it.
And then I'll do this.
Like this.
And then...
But then that's my face.
Hey guys.
No, turn it around.
Turn it around.
Put it further from your face.
And then...
And then I do...
And then what do I do?
What do I do after that?
I don't know.
Oh, I'm kind of...
Oh, you're kind.
You're kind.
You want to end it on FNAF?
No, I'm kind of.
Okay.
Yeah, we can add on to FNAF.
Yeah, let's end it.
We'll do our announcement in FNAF.
Okay.
Five Nights at Freddy's.
Nights.
Okay.
I gotta find a good one.
Ooh, that's true.
The most popular Five Nights at Freddy's.
Yeah.
Okay, I'm submitting.
Oh, sorry.
The camera's in her head.
Yeah, sorry.
We're still figuring it out.
Eventually, I'll learn how to...
Wait, there's like...
Nobody goes to these ones.
There's like...
What?
Is FNAF dead?
Oh, wait.
Wait, this one has 13 people.
Maybe it's popular.
Oh my god.
That one instance with 13 people is for nap dead guys We can
go to this one.
This one looks legit.
I think Okay, I'm gonna put in an instance.
I'm just gonna sit down.
Oh my god.
I know that's a we sit All right, I'm dropping the portal
Right here Oh god, Jesus is a prayer.
Oh,
we have 19 seconds to go through that.
Oh, okay, let's go.
Yay, we're gonna announce something for now.
Woo, for now!
It's time, yeah, so people don't like run, people we don't
want can run into the portal.
Whoa.
Oh.
Man, this is spooky.
This one's scary.
Wait, this is scary.
This is scary.
Yeah, man, I thought you said it would be funny.
Why is it so scary?
Wait, oh my god, we can be friends.
We can be gone.
What's that?
Oh, I turned out the light.
Oh!
What if the battery runs out?
Where is it?
Is there no lights?
I don't know.
I don't like this.
Oh my God!
He made his skin!
What the?
Holy shit!
What the fuck?
He's here!
Oh!
Oh my god!
He's real!
How do we actually turn on the lights?
What the fuck?
I was like, no one's in there before.
Where did that come from?
Oh my god.
Let's hear the shit out of me.
I'm so scared.
Where did you go?
Mint?
Where did she go?
I'm at FNAF 2?
How do you get to FNAF?
How did you get there?
Oh my god.
Where is it?
How did you get to FNAF 2?
It's just FNAF.
Jesus.
Where she left my incense?
What do you mean she left my instance?
Oh my god, the camera is so short when I'm fucking crooky.
Holy shit.
Wait, where did I go?
Oh, there I am.
Oh, okay.
She left my instance!
Wait.
She deceived.
She must have deceived.
Okay, I'm gonna check if she's...
Let's explore a little bit then.
Clearly it's not that scary, right?
Oh, there's legs.
There you go.
Hey, that's where people do that.
Oh, there's my camera.
I go see the FNAF.
I don't want to see the FNAF anymore.
I don't know if I want to see the FNAF anymore.
Oh, is this FNAF 2?
I'm downloading new stuff.
What is it?
Udon Kaikun?
Why are you...
What?
What did she take me?
She took me to Udon Taikun.
Are you playing Taikun?
I'm connecting.
What the fuck is Udon Kaikun?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
doing hot spring or oh let's do it now so are we doing
that's about the hot spring oh sure I just picked a random
place oh I got sent to FNAF 2 and I was scared oh how did
you get to send to FNAF 2 wait let me fix the camera okay
it's okay it was very scary no you want to go back no it was
pretty scary yeah let me grab the camera I don't know we're
at like udon world yeah I was like why is she at Udon Kaikun
oh my god I'm too short I wish you can let other people
control the camera because I'm too short no I'm trying I'm
trying to no we'll announce as Freddy and
Okay, we'll announce as Kroki and Golden Freddy as the hot
springs, the crossover of the century, guys.
Wow!
Yeah!
Wow, the crossover of the century!
All right.
So, because Mint has another stream later on, so we gotta
make this quick.
How much more do you have time to set up?
Oh, not a lot.
Okay.
So, our announcement.
I won't be on the stream, though, but after so.
But Min's going to go prep, and we're just going to chill
after that.
Me and the dragoons.
But, the announcement is that...
So, you guys know that I'll be going to Annie Revolution in
Canada.
And, the thing is, the thing is, I will be doing a...
karaoke concert there and there is around 2,000 seats there
and I invited mid to be a guest at my concert yeah she's
going to be singing there too yeah for those who can't make
it though we will post something we will post we will post
something a little special after the concert for those who
get foam who has foam over it we will have a little bit
something special posted that men and I are working on so so
don't worry you guys can't get to the concert we have
something special that's gonna be uploaded after yeah so get
your tickets um the concert tickets aren't out yet but get
your tickets for the convention details will be out soon
yeah details will be out soon.
Yeah!
Alright, so yeah, that's the announcement.
Are you excited?
That's the announcement.
I'm so excited!
Have you decided your set list?
Have you decided your set list yet?
Uh...
Yes?
I'm very prepared!
Oh my god!
Okay, we've decided our duet set list already.
So, like, don't worry about that, guys.
But, shh, it's a little secret.
You guys are gonna like it.
Shhh, it's a secret.
Oh, oh, you should sing the Freddy Fazbear Tombstone song.
Wait, what is that?
You know, like, FNAF has a song from the Tombstones.
Oh, it does?
Yeah!
I don't remember how it goes, but it was super popular.
It was super popular.
Oh, Freddy Fazbear.
I like to hug and share I will give you a hug And I'll just
squish you like a bug The only tombstone I know is Discord
That's from my little pony
I'm enjoying the hot spring I'm at what I'm not what?
What's the difference?
Are you a Pegasister or a Brony?
Well, are you?
Well, you knew the song.
You knew the Discord song!
What does that make you?
Can I get...
Can I get into the hot springs too?
Yeah, come on in.
How does it look?
What?
It looked like you're about to fucking die.
The one was like singing finale.
at the concerts like we'll just be there and be like and
then you know like in the video there's like the lyrics the
lyrics on the screen and it's just we could do it I'm doing
it well I'm doing Oh my god, the best part was they were
like you don't have you can pick any song too for the
concert They're like you don't have to worry about
permissions and stuff because we can sing anything so
technically we could just be like
That's a classic song.
I know that would be like that's royalty free.
That'd be like the most expensive shit post we've ever done
In 2000 people like waving their pen lights and be like and
the Freddy Fazbear and light to colors like to get everybody
yeah we should do it we should do it That's okay.
Okay, we're gonna leak one song from the set list We will
sing we'll sing a Freddy Fazbear.
We're gonna sing a FNAF song We're gonna no, it has to be
that one.
It has to be that we're gonna be.
Yeah, yeah, what?
I have a mic You mean oh you oh you're you're Freddy Fazbear
I'm already Freddy Fazbear.
Where'd it go?
I don't know where'd it go?
Oh, yeah, it's like hand gesture, right?
Yeah, I think so.
Yeah, it seems like a hand gesture thing.
The crossover of the century.
Crow and Crow Key and Freddy Fazbear.
And Freddy Fazbear.
That's me.
I'll be there.
You get your tickets to meet me, Freddy Fazbear.
Meet Golden Freddy.
You can meet Golden Freddy in Canada!
I'm going to Canada!
Oh my god!
He's going to Canada!
What are you doing?
Hold on.
Is that the bite of 87?
One second.
Wait.
I'm readying it up right now.
You're readying it?
Are you figuring out your hand gestures?
Yeah, I'm readying it up.
Oh my god.
She's gonna Freddy it up.
I'm gonna Freddy it up.
She's gonna do it.
Wait, where did she go?
Oh my god Oh my god, it's a frog
What's your name sir?
Wait, can you say that again?
Can you say that again?
Can you say that?
Can you say it?
He's- He's- Please, please, please.
Please tell yourself, Joey's wanting to go to Canada.
Oh my god!
Frogbert!
Hello!
How do you feel about going to Canada, Frogbert?
Yeah, I'm gonna go there.
I'm gonna really soak it all in.
Oh my god.
You can see the tropical rainforest in Canada?
Oh yeah.
I'm excited.
I've got my sparklers ready for all the excitement.
I'm gonna have.
Oh my god, is Frogbert gonna sing?
I'll sing if a croaky will...
You will have to see if I know.
You'll have to come to the concert to find out.
Yeah!
If someone is making their first Canadian debut.
You guys hear that?
You guys gotta go to Canada, go to see you.
your oh she frog bird do the funky little dance frog bag do
the little dance for us to show your excitement
oh my god he's feeling himself he's feeling himself look at
him he's touching himself right now oh my god smack that
butt I was like, guys, don't miss out.
Don't miss out.
Say goodbye to Frog Bird.
Oh, my God.
We're getting everybody's Oshis today.
Okay.
I'm back.
Welcome back.
Oh, my God.
You missed out.
You missed Frog Bird.
Oh, he was here?
Yeah, he was here.
You missed out.
I think Brock was there.
I think I'm good.
I think that guy is a menace.
He was like, he shook his ass for us.
He like gave us a little smack to like, poop, like that.
It was crazy.
Like, wait, but Brock was just going to be in Canada too.
Are you guys going to cross paths?
Maybe.
If he does, I'm going to have my shank ready.
Oh, that's you.
Yeah.
frog rep watch out she's got her shank watch out all right
thank you thank you to mint for coming here for this not so
special day it's not it's just a normal day yeah for a
little announcement together i had so much fun coming to the
convention oh shit yeah we can and more details will be out
soon regarding the concert everybody so look forward to it
guys i'm so excited to see you all there dragoons and wisp
and everybody else frogbirds and oh she where frogbirds fans
call it tadpoles tadbird the tadbirds
have to well have to maybe if frogbird makes like a vtuber
debut he can come up with something yeah true it's not your
job yeah exactly that's not your job yeah he has to do it
you guys yeah we're all so busy much on my plate yeah yeah
yeah but we hope you see frogbird fans and croaky fans as
well and fnaf fans for those who want to hear us sing fnaf
oh god okay are we actually doing this hyped it up okay okay
guys i hope i need a video recording of of that i will
retweet the video recording of that somebody re records it i
just want to see the pen lights going
i better you guys yeah we gotta see it I better see a fanat
cosplayer there in the audience, too.
I better...
Oh, no.
Wait, who's your...
Which character, though?
Which character?
Oh, it's so hard to choose.
There's Foxy.
I feel like you'd like...
That's true, Chica.
You want a spicy Chica.
That's what she wants.
Then what's who's your favorite?
Chica with a big...
Bajonk.
Someone's been looking at the wrong Chica file.
I don't know.
probably um foxy i like foxy oh you got that fox in you he
goes
oh that's a little dangerous he has the little hook hands
too yeah oh yeah okay i gotta go okay yeah you gotta set up
for your thing i'll see you later all right bye thanks for
coming bye guys i'll still be here i'm gonna still be here
Bye bye mint good luck with your stream.
I'll read it later when I'm done Bye Bye bye bye Yay, oh
she's still here bye
That was fun.
Okay, let me get a little closer.
Whoa.
That was fun guys.
I had a lot of fun I want you all hanging out here just
chill a little bit Um, but a huge shout out huge.
Thank you again to mint for dropping by and, like, hanging
out with me.
I didn't really have anything.
I said, it's not a special day or anything, so I had, like,
not anything planned.
I just wanted to hang out.
But, like, I had to stream the day, so I thought it was a...
I really appreciate Min for dropping by.
Lady was like, Hey, I have no plans.
Do you want to do, like, VR chat stuff together?
And then we can use it to announce our concert together.
So she was like, yeah, we can do it.
Like, after she was like, oh, you want me to...
I can cancel my stream.
I was like, no, no, no, no.
Don't cancel.
um we'll just we can do it like before your stream or after
your stream and then um we're like oh we'll just do a little
short thing and just to announce it and then like you do
your stream your stream is more important because like the
wist want to watch um you know it's a solo stream the wist
won't watch you um but i really appreciate because like you
know she was like oh no it's okay i can i can like i can
like drop by for a bit before the stream and everything and
it was really sweet i was like i owe you one big time
because like you know she i like found out I was like, I was
like, oh my god, I need to, I need to do, I need to do this
announcement.
I was like, figuring out I had to do something today.
So I was like, oh my gosh, okay, what do I do on this normal
day?
Because I figured like you guys would want me to stream
something today.
But I've been enjoying my break and everything, just like
relaxing and chilling in the hot springs.
i've just been like mostly just chilling i guess like i've
been sleeping a lot and i don't have a schedule out yet
because i don't i don't i don't know what to do this week
i've just been like relaxing it's actually been really nice
i've been touching grass i went to the dog park today or not
today sorry yesterday i went to the dog park yesterday and i
brought uh dad over and just like um dad met a lot of like
oh it was so funny because uh when i brought dad over to the
dog part it was like his first time at this particular dog
part and like we accidentally like uh we brought like this
giant ass tennis ball that was way too big for his head and
like he was just carrying around like he was just carrying
around the tennis ball just walking around he's like this is
my ball and then every dog that comes over trying to like
play with him he's like no this is my ball it was really fun
um i've been touching grass and just like relaxing and stuff
so it's been nice it's been nice because that's why i
haven't had a schedule yet because i've been like look i've
just been like um just relaxing i was like i was like oh no
the dragoons i feel like the dragoons were wanting to stream
today and i was like what i do what do i do i haven't been
paying attention i mean of what this is a normal day um but
like um um um but yeah i don't know when my schedule is
gonna be out yet um i also been working on like a lot of
things behind machines and everything and um just been busy
been busy i know it's like counter like i feel like i'm
counter talking myself because i was like oh i'm busy but
also but also i've been i've been busy but also relaxing at
the same time um um oh what a surprise oh it's been uh it's
been a lot it's been a lot of work but it's nice Not
streaming for the last couple of days.
Um, I don't know if I'm going to be streaming tomorrow.
I might do a member stream tomorrow.
Um, I don't know.
Literally, there ain't nothing in my head.
I have, I have nothing in my head at the moment.
I've just been like, I've just been like fucking dead.
I am nothing in my head.
I've just been like, like not dead.
um no thoughts yeah just no thoughts as i tweeted i was like
what do i do this week i don't really i didn't want to play
any video games i just wanted to like like do something
non-gaming related um uh but yeah no thoughts head empty
yeah just no thoughts head empty but thank you everybody for
coming i had like a i'm just gonna check the time oh we have
plenty of time we have plenty of there's any words I want to
visit while we're here.
I need to blow my nose.
Give me a sec.
I need to hydrate.
I haven't even drank any water.
Let me drink the hot spring water.
No, wait, that's unhealed.
It's hygienic.
Give me a sec.
I'm going to mute myself and blow my nose and drink hydrate
because I haven't hydrate at all.
I think guys can hear from my voice.
Give me a sec.
Oh, there's the mouse.
I need to mute myself.
all right i'm back okay i'm back guys but yeah it's been um
been having a nice just relaxing day and uh i'm really
excited um when they told me i'm doing a concert for anime
revival revolution anime revolution um i was like what you
know it's like it was in those moments where i like said yes
to everything when it came to conventions so I I didn't
realize what I said yes to so like they were like it's gonna
be an hour-long concert um and like it seats like 2,000
people I was like what I was like wait wait I said yes to
this I signed the contract for this what I oh my gosh I
So I was like, I was not expecting it.
And I was not, I was not like paying attention at all.
And then so then I was just like, oh no, I don't know if I
want to sing for like an hour by myself.
So I asked like if Mint, because like I know Mint really
loves doing concerts and everything.
And that she enjoys like, you know, singing to everybody.
I was like, Mint, do you want to, do you want to?
you know sing like uh you want to sing in this concert um i
can give you like half the like like give you half the
program if you want um yeah so uh yeah she's really good at
concert so i invited her as a guest and be like you want to
sing because like you know i have you know we should concert
and you know you're you're you love concerts yeah so i'm
really excited and for those who can't make it who can't
make it to the convention and the concert um we will have
like something special that's going to be uploaded after the
concert for those who can't make it i mean it won't be like
you know it won't be like the full set list of like you know
we won't have like their whole recording of the concert
being uploaded or anything but it would be something special
um that we made for people who can't make it um to be able
to like you know also have a fun time and also enjoy
themselves even though like they're not there they couldn't
get because and hotels accommodation it's very expensive so
mint and i we will upload something i think like on my
channel um uh something special uh for you guys who won't be
there um so yeah
i can't wait that's the only song that we're leaking for you
guys that's gonna be in the set list i don't think anime
revolution has like streaming tickets set up like I think
that's like, I don't think they've ever done streaming
tickets before.
I know like that's so much to set up in general because like
you have to make a deal with like these streaming setups,
streaming places, like streaming platforms for like tickets
and stuff.
That's a lot to set up.
So, like, that's like, I feel like that's like not in time
to set something up like that.
Also like with the song choices that we have because like we
can pick any songs too Um We can pick any songs too So like
I don't think like Rights general and general like legal
rights for like song picks What would work if we stream it?
Cause we could literally pick anything we want to sing
Um Yeah we can pick any song They were like they were like
don't worry about what songs you want to sing Um Um, you can
pick anything you want, and I'm like, nice.
This was before Mint got invited as a guest, so I was like,
nice.
Um, she'll only be a guest as a concert portion.
Um, so, like, the other stuff, like the panels and the meet
and greets and stuff like that, it's just me.
Um, but she'll be there for the concert, for those who are
wondering, like, for any whisp that are coming over to see
if there's, like, meet and greets for Mint or, like, panel
or anything, sadly, there isn't.
It's just, um, it's just me for the rest, but she'll be
there for the concert.
I just want to I want to go to another world It's been nice
chilling in the hot spring But I want to I want to go
somewhere new I want stream until Mint goes live and they'll
raid her How many more minutes?
15 minutes Alright let's relax
Let's see Search words I hope the volume was okay I saw like
my sound guy was like Turn down, turn it down Turn it down.
I don't know if I turned it down enough.
I don't know.
I turned down so many things.
I don't know if I turned it enough.
I hope the volume was fine.
Mint moved her stream.
She goes live in 45.
Okay.
Well, I'm not staying in VR for 45 minutes.
I'll just, I'll raid into her waiting room.
I'm sorry guys.
I love mint, but I'm not fucking streaming 45 more minutes
of video.
I would take this off.
Alright.
Boop.
Drop Porter.
I want a cake.
You know, I suppose something else?
To celebrate the snow.
day.
Happy birthday!
Whose birthday is it?
Is it anybody's birthday?
Okay, wait, let me make sure it's local and then look at me.
I'm so bad at this.
Like, I'm so bad at the cat.
I don't know how Mint does this.
I'm so bad at the camera.
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry for my poor rub work everybody I'm trying my best
I'm sorry whose birthday is it today is anybody's birthday
wait I thought this would like have a thing where we can oh
my gosh wait wait can I not blow the candle though oh I can
wait how do I blow it okay you guys can't see that okay
maybe this sit down i've been signing up a long time whoa
all right give me a sec words happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday dear dragons happy birthday
to you yay birthday is there anyone where you can like pick
up the cake and be like that'll be so cool
function that'd be so cute if they did oh my god let's go to
the bar wait actually no let's not some of guys might not be
legal enough to go to the bar i don't want to get in trouble
i don't want to get in trouble with the police okay let's go
to the here maybe here friend plus join
all right some of you guys are not different world different
different countries have different drinking laws.
I don't want to get in trouble with the law.
I don't want to get in trouble with the cops.
Oh, whoa.
Where the fuck is the cake?
How's your... Whoa!
Where's the cake?
There's the cake, guys.
There it is.
Happy birthday!
Wait.
Okay, let me, I got this.
Wait, I don't got this.
Okay, and then we do local and then world and then...
Yay!
Bones!
Oh my god, please, please.
Happy birthday!
Oh my god, please.
Give me a sec.
I'm a professional.
Yay!
It's your birthday, dragons!
Happy birthday Yeah Here you go.
And don't worry.
I got you guys I got you guys some cups some some champagne
some no alcohol champagne Come on.
Oh shit.
I dropped it
Whoa, wait, sorry.
I'm so I don't know how mint does this.
I don't know she does VR chat so often
I can do this better.
Happy birthday!
To another year of this normal day!
Clink.
Oh, sorry, I clinked the camera.
Don't worry.
It's sparkling water.
That's the fizzy part.
It's the sparkling water.
Clink.
Cheers!
to another year of this normal normal-ass day you know what
I feel a little generous today I was like what else can I
announce today I can say that officially by this week I'm
currently working on a 3D modeler yeah who specialized is a
3D model.
I won't reveal who it is, but I'm currently working on a 3D
modeler that has done motion capture models for HALA Live.
Yeah!
Clink.
So I'm excited.
It's going to be a while, though.
What a What a big announcement on such a normal day.
I'm really happy.
I'm so happy.
There's so many good things coming.
And I'm really happy to spend another year with you dragons.
And, um...
And have so much fun.
Every day.
Well, almost every day.
Because I was AFK for three days.
But almost every day!
It's been...
in a wild ride and I hope things calm down soon not gonna
lie I hope I hope things calm down soon because I need I
need so many wild things maybe a little bit too many wild
things
maybe cheers cheers everybody clink
it's been a wild year 24 24 it's been pretty fucking wild
love my sparkling water um but i've been having a great time
spending it with you guys dragons and hoped we go for
another year let me grab your oshi real fast let me grab
your actual oshi in here before we leave you've only met me
like uh you've only met me for like maybe like a couple of
months but um
but what amazing couple of months guys i can't believe it i
finally met frogbird oh my god frogbird and croaky what a
duo i try to i try to convince frogbird to also appear in
the concert guys I'll try maybe you'll see me too everyone
um but it's been it's been wild um I'm gonna cut it here so
but thank you everybody for coming as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stay up for me me specifically
croaky head to bed because You deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Whoa, I need a spin.
Ah!
Don't mind my neck.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Where's the ending screen?
Where is it?
Guys, sorry.
I can't find the ending screen.
Give me a sec.
Where is it?
Wait, where is it?
Oh, there it is.
Bye!